welcome back everybody I'm Barron Holtz
is with us Give It
Up's new show is called history of the
World Part Two it's on Hulu and just
like much of History sometimes on our
show we get stories so long and epic
that they need their own segments so Ike
has one of those stories today so here's
another installment of Epic story time
[Music]
the smile at the end is what does it
Jesse so how this works is I get one
question and from that question Ike will
tell us his story with the help of the
book of illustrations he has right here
so afterward we may have some follow-up
questions
um usually we do but to get us started
here's my one question hey Ike what was
your most memorable experience as a
touring comedian oh well I would have to
tell you about the time that I was in
Europe
and I was very very publicly embarrassed
uh so this is around 1999 okay okay the
Matrix had just come out
that's not in the book but I'm just
giving you some color
I was gonna perform that night and it
was going to be a really big show with a
lot of real comedians people like Jason
Sudeikis oh
the future Ted lasso and uh Seth Meyers
oh Jordan peel yeah some real Heavy
Hitters okay so the day of my
performance I had gone to the beach to
relax we were drinking wine playing
frisbee taking naps it was awesome yeah
it was great well after one little nappy
nap I woke up and I had a little baby
headache and I thought oh I might have
dranken too much wine no problem it'll
wear off
on the train ride home I was like whoa I
am burning up and when I looked in my me
in the mirror I clutched my chest
oh my God I was as red as a fire engine
because I had something called sun
poisoning yes
so I did what any reasonable person
would do I freaked out now I had to do
the show tonight if I missed a show or
if people missed a show it was because
they had bird flu or swine flu or
whatever flew was cool way back in 1999.
not because they drank too much Franzia
Pinot Grigio and fell asleep on a
frisbee which is probably how one of the
lesser-known Roman emperors died yes
stupidest Maximus what's his name that
was his name and my friends were like
why didn't you put on sunscreen and I
was like I don't know I'm dumb and they
were like why were you drinking wine at
noon before a show and I was like guys I
don't know who are you the cops
the worst part of my sunburn was on the
top of my thighs and I read somewhere
that yogurt helps
so I had someone bring me some cold
yogurt and I went to a little backstage
dressing room and I closed the door and
I pulled my pants down
and I started slathering yogurt all over
my thighs
up and down up and downs slathering
I must have gone through a good pint of
Greek yogurt which health tip is an
amazing probiotic
so I'm just sitting there slathering in
my white shirt and my tie and my boxer
shorts with white cream all over my legs
when
here's the thing guys the door to the
dressing room was very close to the door
to the audience woman's bathroom
as I'm slathering myself this woman
walks in on me and I stand up and I'm
standing there with no pants on covered
in Greek yogurt and she looks at me
and she doesn't say a word
she slowly closes the door and backs out
so the relief I got from the yogurt is
instantly destroyed by the worry of what
this woman is thinking about when she's
sitting there in the audience and what
she's saying to her friends and what
she's going to say to her therapist in
10 or 20 years I the guy from The Mindy
Project I walked on in on him slathering
yogurt all over his thighs I'm known for
thinking very far ahead so back in the
dressing room I pull up my pants and I
don't know if you've done this but
pulling your pants up over yogurt
slathered thighs is not pleasant
so in little spots you could kind of see
the yogurt sleeping through my khakis
it's dripping out the sides and I don't
even I I start I start looking for this
woman I start looking for her and I
don't know why right because if I make
eye contact with her I'm gonna get more
self-conscious Kelly so that's when it
hits me
I don't know what it's about my
personality but when I get hurt people
laugh a lot
people love seeing me miserable and at
this moment right now is the most
miserable I've ever been so I do what
any reasonable person would do I take my
sunburn and my yogurt and my abject
embarrassment and I walk out on the
stage and I make every person on that
stage laugh
at me even Ted lasso
via
I
I've never
[Applause]
I've never heard of of yogurt yogurt so
it is a thing have you all heard of that
have you ever put sunburn on a yogurt
sunburn on a yogurt
well either way you could try both and
see which one works raise your hand if
you've ever put yogurt on a sunburn oh
my God you're one one lady thank you and
do you happen to live in uh Holland
it's like listen I don't know where I
got the information from guys it brought
me no relief and only brought me more
misery that is amazing that was rough
you know what so you can survive
anything once you do that once that
happens I I feared nothing I feared
nothing I love it okay a big thank you
to marcelia Marcel
[Applause]
so for those illustrations is incredible
truly uh you can see Ike show history of
the World Part Two all episodes are
streaming now on Hulu
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]